wow I mean first of all I want to jack
your outfit that's so cool I like your
dress it's so cute I didn't know sparkly
until I came in the mail and I was like
surpr that's like perfect for stage I
know that's like the stuff I look for
like whenever form or whatever because
it catches the light it's really pretty
you have the same name I know this is
old news to y'all but it's so funny to
me is it hard like when people are does
it ever get confusing with emails or
questions or yeah what's the most
difficult part the male mail yeah mail
it's yours no it's yours yeah like this
holiday season's going to be tough like
there's going to be some gifts ruined
for
sure opening up of the wrong that's
amazing um TSA like check-ins at the
airport back in they get they like we
need Taylor and we're like that's both
hi yes hello we are both like no Taylor
lner and we're like also oh my gosh it's
just kind of incredible that you found
each other like it's just I don't know
one person named like in my personal
life the fact that there's yeah okay
yeah well now you got it's not as
popular I don't think to me so now I'm
like yeah so wait so your first
anniversary is coming up right it is
yeah are youall doing something fun
first
one what yeah we are we're actually
doing a fundraising Gala for our
nonprofit for our anniversary yeah we're
super excited about it did you purposely
do something not for you like but for
others I mean we've we've been
waiting to do our first Gala or
fundraising evening um for the nonprofit
and it just felt right we when we were
talking about what we wanted to do for
the anniversary we like should we go
somewhere blah blah blah we like or we
could you know we love like sentimental
things so like it just it just like felt
right I think it's beautiful I think
it's a beautiful thing to do on your
anniversary how did y'all meet my sister
introduced us okay yeah they became
friends and as soon as as they became
friends my sister literally called me
and was like I met your future wife you
need to you need to schedule a game
night at your house I think this really
was just thinking back on it this was
her just trying to get an invite to a
game night that I throw but she was like
you need to throw a game night invite a
bunch of me and my friends Taye will be
one of them and we'll just you know see
what happens she had no idea of the
setup yeah I didn't know there was I
just thought I was going to play games
are you a gamer do you like yeah oh wait
that yeah me you're competitive okay
yeah see no I I don't I'm not super
competitive you are I don't I don't I am
I don't let myself be competitive
anymore
because just for the best no okay that
means you're competitive that means
you're competitive now I don't care if I
lose it don't care if I lose but I want
to compete I want to play with people
that want to win yeah we're not playing
have fun yeah I don't want you can have
fun and be competitive yes and what what
game was it that y'all what's your game
night what are you do on game nights a
few different ones running charades
that's running charades why did you have
to make it athletic what like what
flipping charades wait what what does
that mean what's running charades um
okay running charades is you have a game
master who has a list of 10 different
you know songs TV shows movies I usually
like that role because I'm also
competitive and I don't want to get
involved so I just usually be the game
master the two teams are in different
rooms or areas of the house okay you
start with the team captains you whisper
movie Titanic they run back to their
teams in the rooms charade it out
whoever guesses it on their team runs to
the game master to get the second it's a
relay race to get through the it gets
very exciting I love it yeah yeah so I
drafted her on my I was playing that
night and I drafted her on my team and
that's that's where it started yeah all
of game night I like it I like it um so
wait but y'all y'all booked a movie
theater to like see the eras tour yeah
we we had to we've been at a concert
I've been I went a little too many times
um but it was just a fun thing to get to
do with our friends AB all together so
oh no it did look fun um we I want to
show this b-roll so this is video um of
the screening that you had oh no wait oh
there there he is okay wait can I tell
you can I tell you my favorite part my
favorite part isn't even the flip my
favorite part is the drag of the hand it
is like it is like did you just see that
like like do you does he do that often
do you back flip of or the drag of the
hand yeah drag of the
hand he does I mean not like super of
not as often as you used to but he does
flips trying to impress our friends just
like eggiman if forever doing something
they're like do the flip and I say do it
for as long as you can I know I'm try CU
once you hit 40 things change yeah it
feels differently today I pay for it the
next day it was rough after that evening
yeah you have to have like liquid
courage or something like okay so I have
to ask about um something else that
Taylor posted so which one we'll figure
out um but here this is this is amazing
so this is a bath night for for one of
you right this is a oh boy this is a
bath night for you guys getting this
stuff no yeah so do you usually bath do
you usually are you into bubbles I'm I'm
not the biggest she loves baths cuz
they're wonderful
yes I have a a little problem with them
it looks like you enjoy them I was in
okay it took me 40 minutes to set up
that bath I was in it for 3 minutes and
I got hot and then I'm out of it and I'm
like this is a lot of work for like 3
minutes in the bath I used too many
bubbles so I was like what do I do with
them I made a hat but all right all
right let's say you're not into it I got
it I have to ask I know I just randomly
asked I was like was I saying your last
name right I was like wait and I don't
think I was so it's ler it's the proper
way the world has recently learned that
it's been a thing I think so many people
said ler that I thought and I never
corrected people so they just always
thought it was that and I was like run
with it so it's my my staff will tell
it's my biggest thing I always love
getting people's names right so I'm glad
you did that we are correcting the world
today um no but I have to ask so why did
y'all do a podcast what made you want to
do that it's a good question yeah I mean
we both have kind of been passionate
about mental health as like individuals
and now together um I'm a registered
nurse and I work during coid thank you
by the way essential yeah I never know
how to react what someone says that I'm
like you're welcome um but yeah so I
obviously that was um an interesting
time so I ended up having to leave the
hospital due to mental health reasons
obviously my lovely husband has had his
fair share of mental health stuff just
being in Fame in in the spotlight since
he was a kid so it's kind of just a
topic that we've grown to love as
individuals and really learn to
prioritize yeah um but also together and
it's something that we're now so
passionate about I think it's beautiful
that you're both open to it you know
doing that together do you think it's
helped your relationship by doing the
podcast so so much I I think a lot of
times it's communication right is the
problem in the first place so you're
constantly communicating yeah no it's
really great it's it's like therapy
therapy for both of us except free
therapy you got something there yeah
yeah yeah so you the show the podcast
actually inspired the lemon Foundation
right so it's kind of flipped but
honestly they they all are just kind of
one yeah I started the nonprofit about a
year ago um it's called the lemons
foundation so that kind of just started
our world into mental health uh and then
yeah we spun the squeeze off of yeah
it's like a lemon yeah no that's you get
life handy lemons I like the whole play
on yeah that's very very cool so why did
you start the blog did you start it
right after you exited nursing yeah so I
ended up leaving the hospital and you
know I was I was struggling and I knew a
lot of people were struggling because it
was you know heavy yeah it was a hard
time for a lot of people uh so I wanted
to use my platform to kind of just share
what I was going through uh because I
felt open enough to kind of share and
the response was just insane so many
people like everyone not even just
nurses but they were like I that's
exactly how I feel I feel heard like I'm
going through this this is so similar so
that's kind of just how I just kept like
sharing what I was going through yeah uh
and then that is kind of of how we led
to the nonprofit and the podcast I love
that it's happened so organically yeah
now to something fun does he do
something that annoys
you does she do something that annoys
you are there any annoying things that
you've talked about on a topic I'm
giving you like material for your
podcast oh
man go go ahead you got something I'm
terrified no I was going to say one that
you're you've gotten better at because
we've talked about it on the podcast
what um the the
trash what what do you do what like
taking the trash out yeah he'll take the
bag out but he won't put a new bag in
yeah the so it's like he'll do like part
A but not Part B of it and he's he's he
I've gotten a lot better yeah now it's
like once every like five times he do do
you know what I'm horrible at is I am
usually good at taking out the trash but
now living here it's on a different
floor in New York you're all levels
right so now I will take it out put the
bag back but I'll kind of just leave it
right right
until I just make my way down to do
laundry or do something like I'll just
do it in one trip like but then you have
garbage just hanging out next to your
kitchen sink which is not cool yeah it's
not good I wouldn't advise it I need to
aim higher as well I don't do be either
what is what's something that you feel
like she this is another thing that we
have talked about in the podcast as well
is we just we have different
communication Styles and I feel like the
biggest thing you know for a couple or
friendship or any relationship is just
identifying your differences in
communication it's totally fine to you
know to have different styles but you
just need to know the other person's
style so you can understand it adjust to
it instead of becoming frustrated so I'm
a person that has to walk away for a
minute she yeah she likes to process
things too I I Go mute I just don't say
anything he's like well how do you feel
I'm like I have no clue yeah I just need
a minute yeah I have to process so wait
if you have a baby will you please name
it
Taylor I just if you insist just just
something with a t even like I just
think it would be great joked about
naming the first childing Taylor Jr oh
my gosh yeah don't joke about it just
lean in and do it just lean in and do it
I love it I love it my name is um uh
what is it is an androgynous name as
well like Kelly can be male or female I
love though that about names like and
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home